بعد سن الخمسين عند الرجال قد يحصل تناقص
تدريجي في مستوى الهرمونات الذكريه وخصوصا
هرمون التستوستيرون بدرجه تناقص قد تصل
الى 1.2 مما يؤدي الى ظهور اعراض سن الياس
من الاعراض التي تظهر على الرجل البرود
الجنسي والضعف الجنسي تغير الحاله
المزاجيه والعصبيه التعب والاعياد صعوبه
التركيز وضعف الذاكره زياره الوزن وخصوصا
في منطقه البطن
وزياده التعرق
[موسيقى]
كيف يعرف الرجل
اولا عند زياره طبيبه الدوريه بعد عمر
الخمسين وعمل فحص الهرمون الذكري ومعرفه
نسبته لعلاجه قبل ظهور الاعراض او عند
ظهور الاعراب يراجع طبيبي وعمل الفحص
للهرمون واخذ العلاج حسب الاحتلال
اذا ما هو العلاج وكيف نحافظ على نفسنا من
الاصابه بما يسمى بسن الياس عند الرجال
اولا تغيير نمط الحياه بالحفاظ على الصحه
العامه بممارسه الرياضه والاكل الصحي
وتكثير تناول الفواكه والخضار الابتعاد عن
الاكلات الدسمه ثانيا الحفاظ على النشاط
الجنسي مرتين في الاسبوع كحد ادنى كما
اثبتت الدراسات عندما نجد وجود نقص في
الهرمون بسيط فاذا نعطي بعض العلاجات
العشبيه التي يساعد على تحسين الوضع بصوره
كبيره ولكن عنده وجود نقص شديد في الهرمون
يحتاج المريض الى اخذ الهرمون مع تمنياتنا
للجميع بالشفاء
[موسيقى]